there's a new documentary that
celebrates his life and work
it's called I am Heath Ledger here's a
preview before Brokeback Mountain Conan
it would have been unthinkable to have a
romantic tragedy involving two gay
cowboys this is one of the biggest
heartthrobs earth taking on that
character that's an artist he wanted
Fame and then when he got it he didn't
want it supporting actor he will steal
the whole show that's the power of Heath
Ledger here's our entry fees now where's
our trophies this is like taking it to
the next level like you're gonna be
nominated for this I'm telling you right
now you they just smiled
[Music]
the film opens nationwide May 3rd and
can be seen on May 17th on Spike TV this
morning were joined by Derek Murray the
film's director and Kate ledger
Heath's sister good morning to you both
thanks for being more thank you
why now it's been 9 years what what made
you bring this film together now well
you know it's interesting Heath you know
the anniversary of his passing is
actually next year so it wasn't anything
to do with any specific anniversary it
was really that we had a strong interest
in making film about him and as we
started to learn about the depth of him
being an artist beyond acting this great
artist that was interested in
photography and filmmaking we couldn't
resist we dove right in and contacted
the family and the friends around him
and the next thing we knew we were
making the movie to that and there's a
lot of Heath's
own personal home video footage in the
film how much of that was there it's
amazing he used the camera from a very
young age not only to record the world
around him but he also used this as a
tool to perfect his acting skills he
never took any acting classes he took
the camera he pointed on himself he act
there of these various skits he'd look
at the footage and then modify
accordingly it's amazing and hours and
hours and hours of footage okay what was
it like for you to see this film oh well
for me I mean it was an incredibly
emotional experience but just so him
I mean it's I'm so glad that when you
say it was so him what is that it's
truly reflective of who he's really was
and who is that the creative spirit you
know he was more than just the celebrity
persona that I think people saw he was
really multi-talented and and just a
beautiful soul and I think that really
comes through the film what was he what
was it like to grow up with someone who
knew from such an early age that he had
I mean the his creative mind was so much
on display it sounds like I mean he was
just a normal kid you know yeah I don't
think there was any real sort of
difference with him growing up it wasn't
really until he was sort of 17 I think
and what happened well he left home
tried to drive across Australia and
become an actor yeah and that was a that
was huge it was a big step did you have
any indications that he was struggling
near the end I'm absolutely not actually
on the contrary I mean you know Heath
was really happy he was in a great place
in his life and he was making the most
amazing films and he had the best fun
ever
with Batman I mean he could not wait to
show us so I saw a few brushes and he
was just you know I said to him I think
this is it for you've really taken it to
the next level is amazing I was so
excited for him but tonight and Derek
some people say that the darkness of his
role as the Joker in Batman influenced
was somehow influential no I'm just
really honestly it's the exact opposite
we've had so much fun and I think I'm
the only one that watches our family
probably are the only ones that watch
this film and actually laugh because he
was like kind of taking the mickey I
mean he was having a ball in that nurses
you know get up and he just had fun he
had a really great sense of humor and he
found this incredibly fun he said it's
the best time I have ever heard making a
film there was no darkness to it no but
you're so right though that was the that
was the rumor that's what people thought
but you know from the family to the
people that worked on set to people that
worked at them and knew him intimately
this was the most fun he'd ever had
throughout the entire process and after
Derek what did you what surprised you
most in making the film about about
Heath Ledger was a couple things really
but one of the things that you know we
found fascinating right from the very
beginning was how he turned the camera
on himself and how passionate he was
about photography it wasn't a hobby it
was who he was everywhere he went that
camera would come with him and I think
that was really quite amazing and of
course the film has is basically
wall-to-wall with clips and video and
photography that he produced he's shot
you know and that makes it really I've
actually called Heath really a
co-director to the movie yeah Cate what
would he be doing now you know I think
he really wanted to direct and
I mean that he loved acting as well but
I think he had great plans for for his
future directing we're sorry not to see
those come to fruition
there is the documentary that is out yes
Derek Murray
Keith ledger thanks for coming on the
show to talk about Heath and his legacy
thank you
remember you can catch I am Heath Ledger
Wednesday May 17th on Spike TV